[Music]
this is eastern Ukraine conflict broke
out here in 2014 and it hasn't ended
there about a hundred thousand fighters
stationed here which makes it one of the
most heavily militarized areas on earth
there Ukrainian forces to the west and
Russia back separatist militias to the
east fighting between the two groups
occurs here along the contact line in
2015 after nearly a year of deadly
fighting a peace agreement called for a
ceasefire creating this security zone
the agreement was supposed to stop the
fighting and resolve the conflict
between Ukraine and the separatists but
three years later the security zone
remains the most violent place in
Ukraine
[Music]
ceasefires violated almost every single
day in East Ukraine which reportedly
puts about a hundred thousand civilians
in the constant danger over 10,000
people have died since the conflict in
Ukraine began and about 1.5 million have
been displaced while both sides continue
to build up their forces
the conflict began at the end of 2013
when the Ukrainian government rejected
an association with the European Union
in order to build stronger ties with
Russia the pro-moscow move led to
massive protests in the capital Kiev
which turned deadly by 2014 Russia took
advantage of the chaos and sent its
military in to annex Crimea in March
a month later pro-russian separatists in
the dom boss seized the cities of
luhansk and donetsk and declared them
independent from ukraine the ukrainian
army moved to take the region back but
russia covertly joined the separatist
rebels which led to fierce fighting for
several months in february 2015
both sides settled on a peace agreement
called Minsk - the deal laid down
conditions for a ceasefire in the
security zone where heavy artillery
tanks and mortars were banned foreign
militaries meaning Russia had to leave
Ukraine it also recognized the two
separatist areas the Donetsk People's
Republic and the Lu hence People's
Republic and outlined how they could be
reincorporated back into Ukraine but
despite the agreement none of that has
happened in order to understand why you
have to know what Ukraine means to
russia's President Vladimir Putin last
one out of the Soviet Union please turn
out the light the finally important
Ukrainian announced independence for the
Republic the people there are more
Russian than Ukrainians to fear but
Ukraine would be a catastrophe
Ukraine was part of the Russian Empire
in the 19th century and the Soviet Union
in the 20th when the Soviet Union
dissolved in 1991 its western territory
broke into independent states including
Ukraine they formed a buffer between
Russia and Western Europe but in the 90s
and 2000's these countries started
drifting westward and many joined the EU
by invading Ukraine Putin was able to
destabilize and stop it from developing
a stronger relationship with Western
Europe Russia continues to feel the
fighting by supporting the separatists
and keeps its own military at the ready
meanwhile Ukraine's government is forced
to devote resources to its defense both
sides have ignored the ceasefire so far
and a closer look at the frontlines
reveals just how unstable the region is
the separatist rebels in the LPR and DPR
have funding weapons and the assurance
of their massive Russian military behind
them they are responsible for the
majority of the ceasefire violations on
the Ukrainian side the forces are a mix
of Ukrainian army soldiers and volunteer
militias these militias are funded by
Ukrainian oligarchs and members of
parliament
some have far-right views and even have
attacked the Kiev government but Kiev
continues to fund and armed these groups
anyway it's their only defense against
the russia-backed rebels in the east
so despite a ceasefire that could have
ended the conflict there's an active war
on the ground both sides continue to
fire a heavy artillery on a daily basis
as a show of strength power water and
supplies are common targets and the
heaviest price is paid by the hundreds
of thousands of civilians trapped on the
crossfire
[Music]
you